the famous line
the comfortable concentration the home
is a comfortable concentration camp
what was it um
has been translated it's very you know
that she's she is a
you know prisoner in her house
by the way
she actually retracted this very
interesting in her book called second
stage which she wrote some 10 years
after or something like this she said
this was a big extreme for me to say
that
people don't realize she made a hell of
a lot of retractions
why does she make retractions i'll tell
you why she made retractions
she made retractions because in the year
she wrote a book called the second stage
you can you can get this book and she
realized by doing these kind of
sociological investigations that women
were actually having things worse that
things were getting worse for women i'm
going to read something from her book
right now
she said that women are experiencing
more signs of psychological stress than
women in their 20s and 30s had in the
50s and early 60s she admits
listen to what she says and we're more
likely to feel on edge of a nervous
breakdown than young men she says so
this is after what after the civil
rights movement after the implementation
of equal rights act after women are
going to work after all of the the
discussion about feminism after women
were burning bras after after after so
she goes and checks to see if women are
happy now because of what she's done and
she realized actually women are sadder
they're worse off their welfare has been
affected in the negative
and she says that she admits this in her
book the second stage which by the way
you don't find in curricula you don't
find the syllabi this book second stage
you find feminine mystique even
gcse and a levels they don't teach any
kids about the second stage it's a book
she wrote and in fact it's a book she
wrote after the book feminine mystique
but because it has all these admissions
these dirty admissions that she puts and
she tells us the truth about
you don't want to we don't want to we
want to hide this under the cup do we
women 35 to 39 103 she says in the same
book
in the 1970s experienced a nervous
breakdown which was is more than a 10
increase
which is in sociological terms quite
heavy
so she realized
based on her own study this is betty
friday we're talking about that more
women were suffering
after the implementation of all of these
things and after they go into work and
after they she's they've they've taken
up all these attitudes towards domestic
domesticity
and the family and the home and the
motherhood and all these things
you see
and she even admits quite interesting in
the book she goes women have a profound
human impulse to have children well you
weren't saying that before
all the tone has changed now has it when
you see women are suffering and coming
to you and crying and nervous breakdowns
now you're saying well actually women
have a profound
instinct she says or impulse sorry to
have children well you weren't saying
that before fridan she realizes what she
put women in but is she the only one
you'll be surprised she's not the only
one in 1981 after realizing the
troubling psychological impact of women
fridan states this let me just go with
for a second she has we had better find
a change
but change is hard because this is what
she says unbelievable unbelievable what
she says listen to this
she goes
because women have almost a religious
feeling about the woman's movement
allah
she says we've got to change this now
this is 20 years after that she goes
because we're now becoming it's like
feminism has become religion who's
saying that betsy friedan one of the
founding mothers of feminism she goes i
realize we have to make a change she's
saying this i realize we have to make a
change but what but it's difficult now
because women have a what a religious
feeling towards feminism can you imagine
this
a sacredness a reverence an oh this is
what she continues it keeps us from
asking questions about what really
matters to women now
so
you see it's really negatively impacted
women she realizes that
she wants to change that but she can't
because she's already created a monster
she's already created the frankenstein
of feminism she's already helped
contribute to that and now she's trying
to pull women back actually we're going
too far no it's too far the frankenstein
has already been created and and you
know who's suffering for it women are
suffering more because of him
and one of the most powerful things i've
ever read
from a feminist
is from jermaine grey
in her book in 1981 the whole woman
remember jeremiah was one of the
founding mothers of feminism see her see
her online how she's coming with
arrogance and talking and smoking
cigarette and this and that and she's
she's with confidence talking about how
important it is and attacking
domesticity attacking this and quality
and all that kind of and what
she comes in 1981 she goes i mourn for
my unborn babies
i mourn for my unborn babies she says
this is two of your big names
two already we're going to come to the
third one which is the worst one by the
way where she said i'm mourned for my
unborn babies she said
she goes i still have pregnancy dreams
she's exposing herself waiting with vast
joy something that will never happen
because she's over past the age of
pregnancy never happened allah akbar
it's a punishment for you because you
are telling all the women it's you're
telling all the women that motherhood is
xyz and all that now you'll be punished
because you realize that actually you
suppressed your instinct and you hurt
yourself you only hurt you you're
playing with fire you played with fire
and you got burned
who is the ani if you wanna if you wanna
put the main the main woman of feminism
in the second wave is
the second sex because it had been
probably the most robust and thorough
philosophical work that had been done on
feminism and up until the third wave it
was the main way in which uh scholars of
feminism would argue for feminism okay
this is what she says
we know we know her thought right she
attacks
the institution of motherhood she
domesticity she she she talks about
you know how it's so oppressive to be a
you know man and biologically even
and these things but she says the
following she goes she was talking about
she had a boyfriend his name was satra
john paul satra a huge philosopher big
name imagine now she's telling women not
to have what
husbands or this she's telling them not
to have husbands yeah not to be married
not to have kids but listen to what she
says about her own boyfriend listen to
what she said she goes i felt dominated
by someone else intellectually
sartre lived up to the man i had dreamt
up until 15. i was simply not in his
class well i have not seen one single
muslim woman to ever say that
with the most complementarian lifestyle
she's an egalitarian she said i've never
heard anything i've dominated by my
husband i was not even in his class
the most traditionalist woman
the amish i've never said this is what
so you're telling women not to have uh
kids you're telling women not to she's
like the devil wallahi she is like
shaytaan sorry let me just go into
release this goes for that
like the devil he says go and do this
belief and when he does it he says i've
got nothing to do with you in her own
life what's she doing she's saying
you're my superior i'm not even in your
class but she was she's writing in her
books as well
she's writing
don't get married don't have children
don't allow this from the man it's like
this nonsense hypocrite she's a nonsense
hypocrite
she wasn't even married
we'll come on to it she wishes she was
as she even admits well not this but she
goes i was simply not in his class she
she looked in the mirror
just like you added she said something
that you said she i detest my own
reflection
she goes
if at least my own thought had given
birth to a hill a rocket but nothing had
has taken place i'm astonished to
realize how thoroughly i have been
cheated cheated by who are you talking
about by yourself you cheated
yourself
yeah she's writing her autobiography she
thought we didn't read
she
then she also admits i don't know she
thinks it's a diary entry
she writes the following she goes
before her boyfriend satra came from
paris she was preparing her new
independent home in paris and waiting
for the return of satra from paris new
furniture is brought the walls are
papered and new clothes are purchased
oh you're trying to make an effort for
him are you
you're trying to make an effort for him
either but you tell the woman to what
not to get married but you wish you were
married you wish you had that commitment
he called her one time he said to her
because you know she came back home she
wasn't there she said you're like a mere
housewife
and obviously in their understanding
this is a huge embarrassment
she says i was furious with myself to
have disappointed him in this way
and you know he's the one by the way if
you look at her autobiography he
persuaded her
he's the one who persuaded her to write
the second sex so we have a valid
question here was second wave feminism
created by satra by a man was he the one
doing all the work was he the one
pushing her to do these things
why because it is in the benefit we're
going to come to realize it's in the
benefit of a man
it is this is what women don't
understand please some women do of
course but some women don't
feminist women
that feminism second wave benefits the
man
psychologically as we'll find more than
it benefits the woman he doesn't need to
commit
he doesn't need to have kids he doesn't
need all those things he can move him
one woman to another use and abuse
lash and dash he can
this is uh this is the situation
but
let's not uh mention that
what we should mention is some
sociological investigations and the
biggest one that's ever been done that i
know of
is this one that is mentioned it's
mentioned in the poem as well do you
remember what the lines were
yeah this is the last that's going
through
yeah this is the mirror
it's blanche flower and oswald this is
the name of the study 2000 okay a
hundred thousand participants a
longitudinal study from the years 1970
to the years 1990 in the uk and the us
huge study very difficult to replicate
and this is what the researchers said
that men are happier and women are
sadder
in the time period after the feminist
movement has taken force and after all
the laws have been placed and after the
attitudes have changed and after women
are going to work why are they happy on
the saddle well because let me tell you
why
because
they say legislative reform and so on
has not been successful in either
country in either
uh sorry in our country in creating
or uh on right raising the well-being
among women is the core is messed up a
little bit on the flights but that's you
see
this big thing is saying what in fact
the same study said you know who was
getting happier
men were getting happier they're getting
what they want
the commitment issues have gone down he
doesn't have to extract his resources
for her he can do he's got more money
now he can just
use her
move from woman to woman she's she's the
one she wants security she's the one
psychologically primed for these things
you want to play this game with a man
and you think you're going to be happier
you don't know what you're doing you've
created 20 years longitudinal study it
tells us that in fact your the the
welfare of women has degenerated
considerably or exponentially as a
result of what
as a result or after at least these
policies had been implemented
now
why is this the case or what should we
think about
i mean feminists know even the second
word feminist that there are differences
considerable physiological and
psychological and
even biological as we know differences
between men and women
but basically their argument is despite
all of these differences that we should
be treated the same
now the burden of proof is upon the one
who's making the claim why do we need to
be on the back
if they if someone asks you why is it
different for whatever ruling it is in
islam or whatever other system even
that differentiates between ruling and
men and women so why is it different why
should it be the same in fact
plato he made a very interesting quote
aristotle quotes him he says treat like
cases as like meaning identical things
should be treated identically
and different things by extension should
be treated well
differently
now your feminism doesn't accommodate
for the differences between men and
women that's a failure that means it has
less explanatory scope
now why should we cover for their
failure or even accept it as a
presupposition for answering their
questions they're asking why is it that
will come to it but why is the
inheritance difference why is polygamy
why is man can marry this and that why
should it be the same in fact
why is there an assumption of legality
of absolute equality this assumption
itself is unsubstantiated and in fact
they need to argue from first principles
they need to argue why it should be true
different things should be treated the
same
they need to argue that not us
and in fact this is one of the key
reasons
and very important here
why read that happens why apostasy
happens so why shack
happens
why
happens in a deen or a doubt and we
because we've been in the back foot for
too long have not been able to answer
this properly the way we answer is sorry
are you is the assumption that different
things should be treated the same
we believe
that
identicality and value does not mean
so equality and value does not mean
identica that identicality in rules one
more time
equality of value we do believe men and
women are equal in value yeah and
spiritual value they are equal equality
of value is not equivalent to
identicality and roles this is extremely
important sentence to memorize it
if they want
to tell us
that it should be the case they have to
argue for it it's not me that has to
argue for it
but you know what sometimes it's quite
easy
and it's quite straightforward if we
point to them the difference is between
men and women because some of them are
actually ignorant of it even though the
feminist founding fathers were not
ignorant of it and in the chapter
biology but the bovac she goes women are
weaker than men she will lose to them in
the fight she has less control of
herself and paraphrasing but that's the
idea she says in all this thing but
sometimes you have to show them that
that is that is a fact
let's let's giving
let's give some examples of that